I'm for today's bar chart the US
Treasury rally resistance is futile
never ever did I think we've get a Star
Trek reference into my bar charts lot
not only that we have a Borg reference
there are looking at me ball what is he
talking about now all-new Trekkies will
know that the Borg were an alien race
who forced other species into their
collective before doing so they would
say the phrase resistance is futile
anyway fighting the strongest this is
relevant fighting the strongest Treasury
market rally in a quarter century is
like trying to resist the Borg the words
of Nomura Holdings they say it's futile
take a look at this chart this is the
Bloomberg US Treasury bond index which
includes Treasuries with a maturity
greater than 12 months it's now risen
for five straight weeks this is a
one-year chart five straight weeks as
you can see in the top right hand corner
its resting at an all-time high
year-to-date it's gained three percent
only Canadian Belgian slovakian UK and
Danish sovereign bonds have started 2015
stronger in January by the way the
benchmark 10-year note dropped 53 basis
points to one point six four percent
that's the biggest decline in any
January since 1988 the yield on the
30-year Treasury is at a record low 82
fell 53 basis points in January plunging
yields in Europe and making those on
America bought on America's bonds much
more attractive and the dropping yields
could continue to 1.5% on the US 10-year
note from 1.6 four percent so says
Nomura only if stocks falling by the way
analysts still forecast the 10-year
yield at the end of 2015 will be two
point seven five percent that's some
discrepancy between one-point-six
percent today and two point seven five
percent loyal prices are playing a part
low inflation are playing apart
inflation expectations are dropping the
difference on yields
between the 10-year note and
similar-maturity treasury
inflation-protected securities or tips
has fallen to 1.6 six percentage points
from two point two three percentage
points at the end of 2013 a final word
from Nomura buying Treasuries might feel
like being cold with the Borg the market
has now entered into a momentum phase
respect it the US Treasury rally
resistance is futile